quando quando ero bambino avevo un sacco
di sogni ai vostri sogni in particolare
sognavo come tutti quanti noi no di
avere una bella macchina di avere una
casa ande di avere una famiglia di
vestirmi bene perché no perché fa parte
tutto di quello che si sogna di quando
si è piccoli pre quando si è piccoli si
sogna tantissime cose perché si sogna
senza pensare e quando si cresce che si
pensano i sogni allora io dicevo sempre
mai però se voglio avere una bella
macchina devo lavorare duro se voglio
avere una bella casa devo lavorare duro
solo di investirmi bene bisogna che
guadagni bene perché fa parte un po
delle cose materiali
se le vuoi devi fare qualche cosa per
guadagnarti le sapete io vengo da un
paese dell'africa in special modo in
ghana da un villaggio molto piccolo
villaggio che forse neanche segnato
sulle cartine però il sogno che avevano
i miei genitori e da quello di venire in
europa divenire l'italia quindi il loro
sogno si è realizzato
allora quando io ero qua da piccolo ma
portato qua
ero con i miei genitori ci divertivamo
con mio fratello e gli altri a scuola e
non a best trick a feste e al volume
quasi classico ragazze che comunque
viene qua non ha voglia di studiare i
miei genitori seppure comunque famiglia
normale famiglia comune però gli a
scuola è un po classico birichino
talmente birichino che una volta di una
sbarra la mia professoressa di inglese
me la ricordo ancora e poi ringrazio e
avevo degli amici miei che quando
uscivano con me dicevano ma sai che mia
mamma mi dice di non riuscire con the
disco perché perché poi troppo casino a
si può allora possiamo così di gli
avevamo anche un giorno cambierò cece
male non si fida aveva una ragazzina
anche lei italiana perché veniva
spontaneo e uscire con gli italiani
proprio per il 3 a integrarmi meglio
anche lei mamma dice che va beh anche
lei vi dico un giorno cambierà
ok e a un certo momento quando comincia
a crescere
arriva un momento dove tu hai due strade
perché i sogni sono belli ma per
realizzarli
arriva un momento che per tutti quanti
noi io che sono qua
e voi che siete lì abete se un momento
della vita dove tu devi decidere o
raggiunge i tuoi desideri o ti soffermi
ta contenti e allora io dicevo sempre ma
la pro la maestra el insegnato
iniziavano te devi smettere andare a
scuola e di andare a fare il muratore
ma non signora tra fare muratore tu devi
smette andare a scuola e andare in
fabbrica ma non solo nella fabbrica ecco
loro mia di tavano e comunque dai miei
comportamenti di quando ero ragazzino mi
davano già per perso perché comunque è
facile noto vede un ragazzo malato dice
questo qua se arriva ventenne già tanto
ecco oggi ne ho 34 comunque e quando
quando crescevo e quando è arrivato il
momento del cambio mi sono soffermato
ho pensato a quello che mi dicevano e
allo stesso modo ho anche pensato
anzi ho fatto quello che mi dicevano
perché ho fatto un periodo dove alla
fine mi sono messo lì sono andato ho
fatto un corso metalmeccanica perché ero
bravo in fabbrica cose che poi alla fine
ho provato e quel mese li che io ho
fatto in fabbrica mentre lavoravo
pensavo e li ho deciso
wise due strade o ti accontenti di
questa vita per lo malgrado anche i miei
genitori ma lavorato in fabbrica e
chiunque di noi può lavorare in fabbrica
in ufficio
se questo è il proprio sogno va
benissimo ma ognuno deve realizzare i
propri sogni
allora io il mio sogno non era quello
allora ho deciso
ora comincia la mia strada per
raggiungere i miei sogni perché vogliono
ma la macchina vogliono avere a casa
voglio vestirvi bene bisogna che mi do
da fare e perché dico questo perché ho
cominciato la mia strada e quando
cominciata la mia strada pian piano pian
piano che un piano con fatica mi sono
ritrovato ad oggi ad avere attività in
italia
new york collaborazioni a londra in
ghana con un giro di oltre più di 200
dipendenti nel mondo e oggi quelli che
militavano sono ma come hai fatto io non
ho la bacchetta magica diretto è solo
una cosa che alla fine molti di noi che
siamo qua abbiamo dei sogni abbiamo
delle idee ma ci soffermiamo e ci
lamentiamo e perché se deve rilasciare
questo è perché poi dovrei fare così è
perché poi dovrei andar di là ma non so
la lingua no la maestra di inglese che
vive di una band
va bene diciamo un buffetto re gli dico
grazie
perché lei cercava di insistere al fatto
che imparassi inglese cosa che per voi
sembrerà normale voi dite ragazzi di
colore viene all'africa no in famiglia
da messi parli italiano e questo è stato
anche il merito dell'integrazione o poi
ha avuto perché l'integrazione è dato da
me ma se ognuno di voi come ho fatto io
seguo i propri sogni
può darsi che va in un altro paese per
raggiungere i propri sogni a volte
bisogna fare sacrifici e ti ritrovi
andare in un paese che in quel paese voi
che siete italiani dovete integrarvi
quanti noi italiani perché io mi reputo
italiana per quanto creano come voi non
sappiamo in inglese quando ci troviamo
all'estero cominciamo a susa scusa
d'altronde basta così quindi alla fine è
la stessa cosa di quando uno straniero
viene qua cominciò a dire scusa scusa
senza sapere la lingua io dico sempre la
prima padronanza e la prima capacità che
bisogna capire la lingua cioè quando si
riescono a mettere insieme più di due
lingue straniere che ti aiutano a
collaborare a dialogare a comunicare con
gli altri
tu hai già un passo in più degli altri e
questo discorso qua io lo faccio perché
perché ama portato oggi essere quello
che sono ma allo stesso modo quando i
miei compagni e amici che oggi mi
vedevano che mi vedono e che una volta
invece mi chiedevano come mai tu
diventerai farai sono a volte dicono ma
come hai fatto io dico non sono i soldi
che fanno le idee sono le idee che fanno
i soldi io lo posso avere io vengo dal
nulla
per oggi sono quello che sono
e alla fine la cosa importante bisogna
capire che ci si sofferma senza volere
fare un passo in più quando invece se si
realizzano
e quando si quando 11 dice io mi sento
realizzato
ma perché realizzati suoi sogni perché i
sogni si realizzano e quando uno sogni
ad occhi aperti
e riesce a realizzare proprio sogno a
quel punto lì quando gli chiedi ma te
come ti senti realizzato perché realizza
tutto sogno quindi io oggi mi sento
realizzato
e potrei anche dire guarda più fermarti
qua e invece no perché quando tu
realizzi un sogno percepisce una
capacità e percepisce in autostima e per
quello che dico quando ti soffermi sogni
cominci a camminare non ti fermi più
perché alla fine quando ti chiedono come
file non c'è problema senza soluzione e
non c'è una soluzione senza un problema
tu sai già che quando cominci un
percorso ci sarà una precisa la
problematica ma quando lei già superati
una e con me scusate per le donne quando
partoriscono al primo figlio cosa si
dice ma è difficile a dopo che ne hai
fatto il primo gli altri è la stessa
cosa quando hai su passato un sogno gli
altri sogni e idee per realizzarli
diventa una catena perché sai già che
quando eri al problema sai già come
gestire la pressione
questo qua è il concetto che io uso
sempre signori io dico se io sono così
io non sono nessuno io sono uno che è
venuto da un paesino che oggi ha la
possibilità di stare qua e di non
insegnare niente a voi ma come su ogni
avevo anche quello di poter un giorno
poter essere d'esempio per i giovani per
i miei padri per i miei fratelli per
fargli capire e per tutti quanti
stranieri che vengono un territorio che
se tu sei convinto e vuoi realizzati ce
la puoi fare
non bisogna soffermarsi ma bisogna
guardare avanti non lamentarsi perché
quando si arriva un momento della vita
dove si dice
anzi 8 punti di fermare ti giri ti
rigiri e dc cavo in quanta strada che ho
fatto perché alla fine nella vita sono i
fatti che contano
la gente può dire quello che vuole ma
quando cominciò a dirgli
ho fatto questo questo questo questo
questo i sogni e le idee non hanno
colore
tu puoi fare quello che vuoi
e c'è una bella canzone che dice uno su
mille ce la fa e io dico no
il concetto è vero è che uno un sogno
solo uno su mille va dietro col sogno
perché alla fine tutti abbiamo un sogno
ma chi lo realizza veramente e uno su
mille che ci crede al proprio sogno
perché ognuno di voi ha un sogno ha
un'idea ha una capacità ha una dote lo
deve mettere in pratica oggi perché
domani è troppo tardi anche se c'è
sempre tempo per recuperare e dare un
esempio a quelli che ci sono indietro
per quanto io posso dire andata avanti
non fermatevi sappiate sempre che un
passo dopo l'altro
avete una percezione di una capacità più
forte degli altri
grazie